we got jx in the building jeffrey good
result today indeed two wins there was a
loss but nevertheless you started off
the tournament on the back foot how you
feeling about how you're playing now
yeah i felt like i've been improving a
bit day by day the first day was really
a struggle for me i felt like i
couldn't really see things that clearly
and my opponents
outplayed me uh
pretty badly so to come
back
yesterday was pretty decent i had
three draws but i felt like uh i maybe
had the upper hand so yeah just
improving day by day and hopefully i can
improve yet again tomorrow is this your
first grandchild store rapid blitz event
it's my first uh over the board event i
did play in last year st louis wrapped
in books that was held online yeah so
the feeling of playing against these
players live and in person do you feel
like you're playing
up or given your world cup result do you
feel like you're starting to hang with
the the best players i still felt like i
was playing up um i felt like an
underdog especially on day one but
yeah gradually i'm trying to
make myself feel like i belong with
these guys and i can play with them we
know you're a good blitz player are you
looking to pick up a lot of points in
the next two days
uh not necessarily i'm hoping to have
some fun i think it's going to be a
really fun day very exciting
and yeah hopefully i can limit my
blenders tomorrow
final question this game right here talk
about this exciting wild one that you
played against sam it looked completely
insane
b4 at one point sacking the exchange
later or playing bishop e5 in the wild
position how did you feel when the game
was transpiring
yeah it was a very typical mess i think
it was quite riddled with mistakes but
in the end basically
i mean both of us were just low on time
and i was just making random checks to
see if uh i could
you know trap him somehow and it worked
out for me so i guess it was pretty
fortunate to win to be honest well we
hope good fortune for you in the next
couple of days uh congratulations thank
you jeffrey rate yourself for a quick
second for our audience
do you see yourself
classical chess rapid chess or blitz
chess what's your best discipline
uh yeah it's a tough question um
i actually probably like playing rapid
the most
not not too fast but not too slow either
very good well we'll look forward to
seeing how you do in the blitz good luck
jeffrey thanks